as the NHS reels from Friday's
cyberattack there are new concerns over
how it handles data not in terms of
security but patient privacy Sky News
can exclusively reveal that google
deepmind the search giant's artificial
intelligence arm may have received the
personally identifying medical records
of 1.6 million NHS patients here at the
Royal Free Hospital on a legally
inappropriate basis that's according to
a letter sent by the National Data
guardian Dame Fiona Coe dekat this is
the letter sent by the National Data
guardian obtained exclusively by Sky
News and at the heart of it is the issue
of consent whether 1.6 million people
really gave their permission for royal
free to share their most sensitive
medical information with google deepmind
bought by google in 2014
receive the patient data to test an app
called streams a healthcare platform to
monitor patients for acute kidney injury
and rapidly inform clinicians notices
here I've been using it for eight weeks
and praise its impact so just even today
I got alert about ten minutes ago to say
and somebody's [ __ ] was an acute
kidney injury level three so three times
above the baseline and went to see her
immediately she's got a really high
white cell count which is a mark of
infection so we have stops and
medication add some antibiotics given
some fluids and we'll be monitoring her
for the next 24-48 hours there are
strict laws ensuring the confidentiality
of NHS patients data under common law
though patients are implied to have
consented to their information being
shared if it was shared for the purpose
of direct care but in the letter gained
Fiona wrote my considered opinion
therefore remains that it would not have
been within the reasonable expectation
of patients that their records would
have been shared for this purpose I
absolutely understand that patients
would expect health care professionals
and organisations to push the boundaries
to use new IT to deliver patient
benefits to save lives and to reduce
complications but I also understand that
patients and I'm a patient myself expect
their data to be treated with
confidentiality and we are absolutely
committed there all three as I think the
Health Services generally to make sure
that we get that
to face and those boundaries right deep
mind itself is sensitive to patient's
concerns so I think one thing that we do
recognize that we could have done better
is make sure that the public are really
informed about how their data is used I
think it's a wide scale concern across
the NHS that we don't tell patients as
well as we should how the debt sensitive
data is used that's unlikely to assuage
critics of the deal though the way that
this is developed has actually shown
that they really made several
fundamental errors at the beginning and
not fessing up to them and not dealing
with them appropriately it's really
putting other projects and the public
faith in data sharing deals which have
tremendous potential in real peril it's
possible there might be another legal
basis for the data transfer that's what
the Information Commissioner's Office is
looking at now the conclusions of their
investigation are expected soon
Tom Cheshire Sky News